wireless just spontaneously jumps to
another
okay i don't know why that is oh that's
weird okay um
let me just tell the listeners switching
streams
okay uh let me finish this one up and
end this broadcast
um so let's see if we have people
listening in the chat room he is being
let me
cancel this okay so we should now be
live
again let me just check to see something
lenny how are you doing can you say
something to the audience
hello everybody good morning good job
nice to meet you
it's nice to see you
how can i see the audience i can't okay
you can't see the audience you can see
me
i see you all right good
so we are back live on the into the
impossible podcast welcoming lenny
suskin who is a
good friend mentor to many of us so just
reminder we're going to have kamran
vapha
lenny's friends cameron vaffa barry
barish ray weiss is also coming on
in the next week or so and we'll have on
shelly glashau who's a fellow alum of
bronx science lenny's alma mater
we're just remarking how much fun it is
to do talks in your pajamas but also
missing out on the um missing out
on the uh pleasures of interacting with
colleagues and
especially uh lenny's colleague stephen
hawking uh lenny i'm sorry could you uh
just say again
what did steven mean to you personally
as a foil he wasn't the easiest person
to get along with i remember
hearing that from many people but um but
he had this magical
captivating effect on all of science
so much so that if you asked any person
who's the most famous scientist they
would say someone like stephen hawking
not me
well there were many aspects of stephen
hawking first of all he was a great
physicist there's no question of that
uh maybe it was a little bit of a
stretch to say that he was einstein or
newton
but he was a very very very important
influence in physics
uh but you know there were other aspects
to him that
that certainly caught people's
imagination his stubbornness
against uh against well over
overwhelming
odds how he managed to
to not just survive but to flourish
and to do great physics when he could
barely
move no more than his eyelash this
is an incredible story so he was in
addition to being a great
physicist and a hero to physicists
because of his
physics he was a gigantic he wrote
in a much bigger sense that being said
he could frustrate me he could annoy me
he could anger me but not because of any
personality glitch
but because i was very frustrated
by um by let me call it his
incredible stubbornness not to recognize
the
to my mind not to recognize the
importance of his own work in a sense
he had asked an extremely deep question
a question that uh that has dominated
theoretical physics ever since the uh
for you know for 30 40 years now
but i felt he had taken the easy route
and tried to find an easy answer when
the answer was far more subtle and
complex
his recognition of the question was
monumental
his answer was probably not
his answer was information is lost in
black holes
that seemed wrong and i wanted stephen
very much to
realize that his question would lead to
something much
deeper than what he uh than what he had
envisioned
so he was that's right he was a very
complicated man very complex
and interesting for sure the problem was
hard to communicate with him just
because he's
physically hard to communicate with him
i remember once seeing him speak at a
royal society meeting
that i had somehow uh stolen someone's
invitation to attend
and stephen was there out of the guest
and it was 1996 or so
and someone asked him a question and
this is when he could still move his
finger
so he said they asked him why did you
write a brief history of time
it's rumored that no one understands the
entirety of this book and no one's even
read it
and stephen answered in his inimitable
uh synthesized voice
i wrote it because my daughter needed to
go to college
and his sense of humor comes across of
course your books are known for their
clarity
uh but not for their dumbing down i
actually uh learned quite a great deal
not that it's like some great encomium
to hear from
some nobody like brian keating that he
benefited and profited greatly from your
book
but some of the topics that you talk
about are more relevant than ever
nine years after its publication and i
want to ask you
in the intervening nine years since you
wrote the book what has changed what
would you write differently if you were
to write this book again other than
lamenting the loss of your of your
friend and and rival in
in a friendly way stephen hawking
actually i think i wouldn't write
anything different i think i would write
almost exactly the same thing but the
difference would be
that i would have written another book
right afterward on the follow-up of what
happened afterwards
the follow-up of what happened
afterwards in the last when did i write
that book
2005 something like that does this now
let's see if i can do the arithmetic 15
years later
the subject is the subject and the
subject means the subject
of the quantum mechanics of gravity
that subject has not only expanded but
it's been clarified
not more than clarified almost
revolutionized
by new ideas ideas that i did write
about in that book
but which have developed extraordinarily
uh
surprising directions so i don't think
it would have changed what i wrote in
that book i would have written
another book afterwards um but i don't
know if i have the
i don't know if i have the endurance to
do uh to do it
yeah i mean when we think about books so
your most famous paper i looked up you
know citations i forget what it is it's
several hundred two thousand citations
this book and your other book uh the
cosmic landscape
i think uh that book sold tens of tens
and tens of thousands of copies
what's the difference when you write a
popular a book for a popular audience
that has a lot of
red meat sorry to my vegan fans but
versus writing you know a paper which
might be read by a few thousand nerds at
most and maybe not even all the way
through
versus your book writing for the popular
audience that's consumed
rapidly by hundreds of thousands of
people well
uh in some senses it's similar
but first of all i've always gotten a
lot of
not just pleasure but i think more than
pleasure out of explaining things i like
to explain things
and there are at least two reasons why i
enjoy explaining things so much first of
all i'm a ham
and i really get a kick out of showing
people how clever i am and how easily i
can explain things which sound hard
so that's uh that's one aspect of it but
the other thing which
is very important is the process of
explaining
for me teaches me a great deal about the
subject i'm explaining
and the more i try to explain it to a
less and less technical audience the
more i learn
new ways to think about things so it's
an important
part of my own physics the process in my
own head what goes on in my head when i
try to explain things
on the other hand the business of
writing
a book like the black hole war gave me
an opportunity to try out something that
i'd never tried out before
that was to write about people to write
about myself
when i write a physics paper i don't
write about myself
and if the paper happens to have um
reference to stephen hawking or somebody
else i don't write about them
i write about their equations this was
something i had
always wanted to try my hand as a writer
and see if i could both write a little
bit about myself about the people i knew
the uh the whole human
aspect of uh theoretical physics
and i found that i found surprisingly
much to my surprise that i had some
ability to do it yeah
terrible i had a terrible uh time as a
student as a young student
with my english classes
i was always considered a very poor
english
student i don't know why that was
you talk about your childhood and and
even going to yeshiva university
i didn't go to you oh sorry i was a
professor there you were a professor at
yeshiva university
i was a professor you're at cornell
right i did not have a religious
upbringing not at all
i don't want to talk about that
obviously that plays a role we've had on
guests ranging from you know the world's
famous most famous rabbis to the world's
most
devout atheists and i think you you i
know where you where you stand but i
want to get back to what
you talked about accidentally i did go
to ccny at the city college just uh
that's right sorry yes and uh that's uh
what your friend and also
fellow graduate uh shelly glashow talks
about in his book
interactions i have that somewhere he
calls ccny the circumcised citizens of
new york so
he might go there he didn't go there
either but no he had an opportunity to
be a professor there
and um it's too bad because he could
have had a good career you know if he
went to if he took the job at cc no
ccny's a wonderful
institution i don't want to disparage it
um in any way but uh but you talk about
you know having a little bit of a
of a maybe it was a a complex but maybe
it was more of a chip on your shoulder
and i see you as
you know one of you're a brawler you're
one of these tough you know new york
jews i i hate to keep bringing up our
common background but
but the point is i think i characterize
you as fearless
i don't think that you're you know
infallible but i feel like you're
fearless and i wonder if that
modest upbringing you had with parents
your parents didn't go to college right
no no no no my father got through the
fifth grade
my mother i think got through the tenth
grade
and now you're a member of the national
academy of sciences what does that feel
like did you ever have what we call
imposter syndrome in academia
ah boy did i i don't think i felt that
was impostor because i felt i wasn't
talented
but you know i came from this very
working class background my
formative years up to the age of about
22
most of the people i knew were very
working class my father and his plumber
friends
i was a plumber for a while uh and
ccny was not a place where you got the
the
harvard what should i call it patina
it was full of working class kids like
myself
we didn't live on campus we we took the
subway to school so
so when i finally got to graduate school
i felt very out of place people were
extremely kind to me at the
cornell they felt i had talent and they
were extremely kind to me
but i felt out of place i felt i was in
a world
that i didn't uh that i didn't
come from and um
felt awkward in it and i i don't know if
i felt i was an imposter
but i did feel very much an outsider and
i did wonder do i really have as much
talent as i hope i have
and to justify how nice people were to
me
so yeah and i think that lasted a long
long time
and i felt like an outsider until i
suddenly discovered i was the ultimate
insider on the subject how do you mean
how do you mean the ultimate insider i
mean well i
began to discover that half the
population of theoretical physics had
been my students so my
post-docs or my all my close friends
and um i also began to feel much more
comfortable in the academic world
just probably because uh people listened
to me
people tended to accept what i said
i think i was probably 50 before i began
to feel comfortable in the academic
world
wow and that was long after you were at
stanford right i mean this is long after
i was in stanford yeah
i went to stanford when i was 37 38. wow
and uh to what do you what do you
attribute what would you recommend to
somebody
younger person now not quite 50 who
still struggles with this who has
kind of this alternating view of himself
or herself as
as talented as curious what what's the
test what's the metric that someone can
use
to keep encouraging them to go on okay
so maybe i won't give any advice about
how to get out of that predicament
but maybe i will give some thoughts
about how to use that predicament
please yeah i mean i think uh very
likely
my own sense of i won't say inadequacy i
i didn't feel inadequate
my own sense of discomfort
probably to some extent
may have led me to to be more
independent
more and to push harder on
ideas maybe i just wanted to succeed
because uh because i did have this
feeling of
outsideness so i i would say just
whatever your whatever your um
uh what's the right word
whatever your sense of not belonging or
whatever it is
use it you probably can't get rid of it
that easily
use it find a way to use it and you even
have encounters on the
you know sacred grounds of of cambridge
and oxford and utrecht and all these
places that you recount
the book is an adventure story i kind of
think of you it's a cliche but you know
the indiana jones of theoretical physics
but i do feel like uh sigmund freud once
said something to the effect that
you know a man who is loved by his
father and mother
uh in some sense is like destined for
greatness and it applies to women too
do your parents give you confidence i
mean you weren't raised jewish what was
your
you know parents jewish i mean you were
raised jewish but you weren't
you're not believer now so what was your
well no way that wasn't raised religious
yeah be careful i mean yeah i was i was
raised quite jewish out of a different
tradition the tradition
was jewish leftism leftism uh
coming uh from uh before before there
was the soviet union my parents my
parents
my my parents my grandparents came out
of
eastern europe at the time of the czar
and they were leftists they were all
leftists they were not religious
i suspect my father's family were
atheists but uh
they were and that's the that's what i
grew up in but it was very jewish
um what it wasn't was religious
and when you meet people as you talk
about in the book ranging from feynman
to uh to to you know obviously stephen
hawking had the use of none of his you
know real
physical faculties but he kind of
depended as much on his
mental acuity and uh and so forth you
talk a little bit about being
disappointed
recently um you know that maybe he
didn't take it as seriously as he should
have i mean he was known for these bets
i always
found that you know there was a famous
signed wager outside of uh in bridge
hall at caltech where i was a postdoc
after getting fired from stanford we'll
talk about that some other day
but uh but that you know poster of the
bet with kip thorne which kept thorn had
to concede
uh because uh and i think it was over
like a subscription to playboy or
something like that but stephen was this
mercurial figure
and and i wonder you know you talk about
how
yeah it was almost like a feeling of
frustration like you want that
competition
you thrive on the kind of battling and
the resistance that we get
from our colleagues and i wonder you
know we've lost that i mean you're
you're you know closer to
to you know to um you know the the
the interaction with stephen than i ever
was i just met him that one time
but when you think about um you know
physics today is it
has it changed you know for the better
or for the worse in terms of
the conflict that we now see move to
social media and twitter i know you're
not on that which is why you're so poor
uh so nowadays we see like these battles
like today there's a battle about life
on venus
you know and it's being waged on twitter
what do you make of that compared to
your battles in person
it's terrible it's terrible um
okay life on venus
the the war over
not only i don't mean the black hole war
i mean
was around much nastier war over whether
string theory
is uh is a contribution to science or a
contribution to anti-science
that takes place on the blogosphere and
i i do from time to time read some of it
i think is very very destructive
how is it destructive it's foolish it's
silly
largely that people don't know what the
hell they're talking about
and especially if you read the
commentary that comes after the
things that the bloggest says they can
be endosylic
they can truly be imbecilic what does it
do what is its net effect
i think it adds to the um to the
sense that you can't trust scientists
now scientists are not always right
they're but they do try there's
very very little in in my experience
there is
very very little dishonesty in the
science that i think i
am involved in maybe no dishonesty or no
they can't
say none but very very little
and when you read these blogs you would
think that every string theorist is
doing what he's doing
only to be able to get more money from
the nsf
this is utter bs
and uh yeah so i said i think it's
dangerous i think it's dangerous and i
think it's counterproductive
and i damn well wish it would go away um
well
amen to that uh i know you sure
you know paul steinhardt my friend at
princeton university feels the same way
and he actually feels it's even more
invidious than
as you recount because as you know
sometimes you have tentative ideas as
i'm an experiment i'm just a simple
experimentalist closer to a plumber
uh than you ever are nowadays well okay
but it's such a misconception
i'm just kidding uh you know jim simons
once told me a joke about plumbers he
said he
had to call a plumber once and the
plumber came to his house early in the
morning to fix some leaky
toilet and jim asked him how much do i
owe you and he said uh 800
and the and the plumber and jim simon
said what are you talking about 800
you're only here for 15 minutes you know
i i don't make even i am a hedge fund
manager i don't make
thirty two hundred dollars an hour and
yes he does
and then but no then the plumber says
you make thirty two hundred dollars an
hour
that's what i used to make when i was a
hedge fund manager
so don't underestimate you did you say
you're going to interview shelly
glacial tomorrow yes okay remember to
ask him
about how i fixed this toilet his father
was a plumber too incidentally
that's right that's right i remind him
to remind him to mention how i uh how i
fix this toilet
okay i will ask of that though uh so uh
but getting back to it
uh what paul steiner would say is that
sometimes you have these tentative ideas
as a theorist again i'm relying on your
experience not mine
and they're not ready for fully being
vetted because you need to ruminate
marinate them in your mind
but with social media now this gets
leaked out and you say you're giving a
talk and someone takes a picture post it
online and
and then you can be ridiculed so i agree
i think it is very pernicious um
uh and i wonder you know uh if if it's
if it's irreversible is it like a
ratchet
it's not gonna go back what do you think
oh god i don't know i
um things come and go and i don't know
that's something i can't predict um and
since i'm not particularly a social
media person
i i probably see less of it than most
people but i do see some of it and it
irritates me to no end
um yeah it probably won't go away now it
has very little effect on the physicists
themselves and what they do
none whatever i would say but
uh i think it has an effect on the
public that
people tend to trust science and
scientists
less because of it yeah i know i i look
at it
i'm always amused when someone says
trust scientists um
i don't know a scientist who just trusts
scientists without a reservation
of course subject matter experts should
be listened to
but i think blindly obeying you know
just because someone's a scientist i
mean look
there's a lot of misinformation that
masquerades as science as well
yeah that's absolutely true um but
that's that's absolutely true how did
you react to the
um uh not only to the event horizon
image
of the event horizon of a black hole um
but also the
uh the nobel prize to andre aguez
and to reinhard genzel for the discovery
of a compact object they went another
way not to say
it was a black hole but a compact object
what does that data feel like when you
look at it
don't look at it
okay look i'm not in the least bit
amazed
at this point at this point in history
that there are black holes out there
of course there are black holes out
there we've known that for a long time
that's not the point what i am amazed at
is two things first of all the ability
of the human mind to have even created
the i
not they didn't create the idea absorbed
the idea understood the idea
the whole idea that the a couple of
pounds of gray flesh
could have uh could have conceived of
understood and developed the ideas of
general relativity and all that sort of
stuff
is amazing and it's more than amazing
it's
uh otherworldly and
on top of that the ability of observers
and experimenters
to be able to figure out how to actually
observe
and do those things in the subtle subtle
technology that went into it
which i don't know a great deal about
but i can conceive of it
is really off scale so i would say this
particular thing was a great triumph
of observation and experimental physics
being able to see something which is
extraordinarily difficult
have conceived and built
the machines and the the apparatuses
which was so subtle and so fine
that they were able to see something so
hard that we that when i was a young
physicist we couldn't conceive of being
able to observe a black hole
so it is a triumph it's a triumph of
theory
but it's even more so this particular
thing that you're talking about
a triumph of experimental science yeah i
wonder uh this because i
don't very often get a chance to talk to
uh
folks like you uh although i do have
some great guests on the show again
reminder tomorrow shelly glashow cameron
vapha
and john presquez coming up these are
all characters in the black hole war and
they're very much
real non-fictional characters i asked
all of them i asked roger penrose this
too i said
um you know part of the citation or part
of the recognition that you received
this
you know golden this is a my gelt
version of the nobel prize that i got
when i was at the
nobel museum 10 years ago but the part
of the
part of the you know motivation is your
work on singularities and i asked him
um why should we think there's a
singularity i always have
an issue with this it's almost like
these snakes that you talk about
the uroboros the snake that eats its
tail we say that we need a singularity
because quantum mechanics
you know is not well understood in the
vicinity are sorry gravity is not
understood at the quantum mechanical
scale
everything in the forward direction
heads towards the singularity
we talk about the big bang and the big
bang being the singularity
um you know hawking penrose hawking
hardle
um we talk about these things but it
seems like you need to justify quantum
gravity because there could be these two
regimes that are
in principle unobservable namely the
core of a black hole and the beginning
of the universe
to what extent would you bet your
neighbor's pet ferrets life
on the existence of a singularity do you
think they really exist
about the cosmic singularity at the
beginning of the universe i
i uh don't know
and i'm somewhat suspicious i think a
singularity in the sense
that in that sense uh we simply don't
know
the and the uh the singularity inside a
black hole
what the what the singularity means is
it doesn't necessarily mean a
mathematical singularity
what it means is the place where things
get so dense
and so hot and so um dense i guess is
the word
that the laws of physics as we know them
break down
or at least were the classical laws that
went into
general relativity breakdown and so we
can't really we don't really know what
happens there but what i would say is
this
up till now far more interesting than
the singularity
has been the horizon of a black hole
the horizon of the black hole is as
quantum mechanical in its own right as a
singularity itself
and the horizon of the black hole is
observable
that is what we observe when we see the
black hole
well i mean technically we're seeing the
light shadow in the event horizon
telescope right it's a little different
than the
stretch it's certainly not the stretched
horizon which is no we're not
well we're not we don't
directly see radiation hawking rating
the only thing that comes out of
the horizon is hawking radiation we
don't see that that's correct
what we see though is you see a black
disc
the black disc and around the black disc
you see these rings of light
those are rings of light which have been
focused by the gravity of the
of the black hole the black disk itself
the radius of the black disk is not
something that has to do with a
singularity it's something that has to
do with the horizon
that that black disc if you like
is um its size its properties
are the horizon now if you could see
really clearly
and in a sense the um the gravitational
wave
detectors do see fairly clearly what
happens to the horizon when it's
perturbed how is it perturbed it's
perturbed by another black hole crashing
into it
and when you hear the ringing noise and
the sound that's produced by these two
not the sound but the uh the
gravitational radiation coming from it
that is pretty much direct observation
of the horizon of the black hole
so at the same time that you were
engaging when the first opening skirmish
between you and stephen hawking took
place
in 1981 stephen remarkably i think that
was when he was at this new field
uh symposium around the same time with
steinhardt
and and uh and others and they were
debating the
nature of inflation and i wonder just
before we leave
uh the notion of the reality of
singularities i wonder
you know if god you know i know who you
don't believe in
um uh if god handed you a letter and
said the big bang is actually like roger
penrose uh thinks it was it's this
conformal
cyclic cosmology that goes on eon after
eon we'll get into that later
in other words there was no big bang
singularity um what would that do to
your bayesian priors about the
physical existence of a singularity i i
understand what you said about
mathematics but
the physical existence of it would that
decrease your credibility or
let's let's be very specific we're
talking about about this oscillating
version of
uh that both paul steinhardt and roger
penrose have advocated
yeah they're they're saying god why did
you violate your own laws of physics
you have violated the second law of
thermodynamics
even you can't do that
if you did do it if you did do it i will
never trust you again
second law the second law of
thermodynamics is one of the most
fundamental logical laws of physics i
don't believe you
so it's sacred of course that's what led
roger to his
you know claim that the entropy is is so
improbably
low yeah that's fine that was fine
okay but this idea of this universe
which is pulsing
no that's a perpetual motion machine
that violates the laws of
thermodynamics and boy those are the
ones that i don't
i don't i don't like oh actually okay so
paul
no i'm not talking about i know well
don't you do that i'm his uh surrogate
i'm his prophet the navy
the navy brian keating um i want to say
uh yes so it is true that that paul has
this um
this special contrivance and actually we
have debated that he and i
uh but paul's model uh doesn't depend on
a perpetual motion it depends
[ __ ] paul's model is a perpetual
motion machine i have explained that to
an endless number of times he agrees
with me by the time that we're finished
through the discussion
and then he goes on to say it again now
let's go on to something else because
this will become a perpetual emotion
okay fair enough no i don't want to i
don't want to continue this i know okay
all right i'll move on
um so we talk about uh you know this
this notion of um
of of when we look at something uh the
black hole singularity gets all the
media attention but it's actually the
stretched horizon
that betwixt is you can talk more about
why what was that like first of all
lenny because i'll never get to do this
what does it feel like to make a
discovery like that
on a personal level let's get personal
don't you know i don't i i can
understand the mathematics but what does
it feel like to make a discovery like
that and why is it so much more
important
or as important as the singularity which
gets everybody's attention
okay uh
i made a number of discoveries in my
career probably
the first one was the discovery of
string theory
okay the uh and it's probably the most
famous one in the sense
um well it's very exhilarating
it's also nerve-wracking uh because
you're hoping
very much that nobody else out there has
made the discovery
and that you're alone that you're the
one who has
discovered it first and you don't know
that for sure
somebody might be right behind you or
right in front of you
very much that happened exactly with
string theory with me i discovered
shortly afterwards after this enormous
exhilarating feeling of having
discovered something that nobody else
knows that somebody else did know it
nembu
the great physicist nambu had written at
just exactly the same time
maybe within a day discovered exactly
the same thing
and so that was a bit of a letdown on
the other hand at the same time
i felt wow i had done something that the
great mambu
had done and uh so
yeah it's it's nerve-wracking it's
exhilarating
it uh you want to get it out as fast as
you can
because you don't want to get late with
it you don't want to get scooped
uh and
that's the way it feels so maybe we will
get you on twitter lenny
you won't get scooped ever no you won't
now now that stretching the stretched
horizon is as fascinating as the
singular okay so the stretch the horizon
was and i
uh yeah i mean um
what to say the idea that the
or first of all there was an old idea
a very nice idea that was due
i'm trying to remember exactly it was a
french relativist
and i know him quite well and i can't
remember his name off the oh
uh uh thibal gamor tebow da moore
and followed by kip thorne and other
people who are general relativists
had put forward this idea of they called
it a stretched horizon it wasn't me
but they had a slightly different
meaning they had
the stretched horizon was something that
could sit outside the horizon but it
wasn't physical
it was just an arbitrary mathematical
surface that you put
around the black hole which was just
there for mathematical bookkeeping
reasons
and they had worked out a whole theory
of the behavior of black holes
based on this stretched horizon idea
what i think my contribution was to say
yes if the stretched horizon is real
it's a real place
just above the horizon of a black hole
where quantum mechanics becomes truly
important
where the temperature of a thermometer
that you would lower
down into the black hole would become
enormously large
that there was a rea a genuine real
place just above the horizon of the
black hole
which in which all the information that
falls in
onto the black hole resides
where it sits there it boils and
eventually boils off little bits that we
call hawking radiation
that was that in itself was not
really a really wasn't a new discovery
and um what was the new idea was that
could coexist
with the idea that somebody who falls
through the horizon
will not see that somebody doing
measurements from
above the horizon let's say in an orbit
an orbiting space station around the
black hole
can send down probes long
wires with uh with thermometers attached
to them
pull them back up and get records of
what they saw
they would discover this stretched
horizon extremely hot
extremely complex degrees of freedom
and at the same time somebody who just
fell into the black hole
would not see any such thing this was
called
black hole complementarity
complementarity of two descriptions and
that was
that it was that which was really the
the revolutionary radical idea
what would happen one of my guests is uh
[Music]
uh
members in the chat room subscribers
asking what would happen if you
performed a bell
test of kind of bells inequality test
near the horizon what what would
change about violation of bell's
inequalities if anything
nothing nothing nothing but uh
nothing no you know there's various
things you could do you could sit
outside the horizon and
do a bell experiment on two electrons
outside the horizon both of them outside
the horizon
and in that case nothing it would just
be the same as doing it
anywhere else more interesting
possibility is you drop one electron
into the black hole and the other one
you leave on the outside
and then you can ask can you do a bell
experiment
in which the two things which are
entangled are the electron on the
outside
and the entire black hole and the answer
is yes
in principle you could do a bell
experiment in which
one of the subsystems was the electron
and the other subsystem was the black
hole which
had absorbed the electron
so yeah bell bell inequality experiments
in principle would work
whether they were done uh
either way so
well however i would have to say i would
have to say that stephen
hawking would have denied that
he would oh he would have said that the
electron which fell into the black hole
all of its information its quantum
information was lost
and so the one which remained outside
would not remain
entangled with anything ah okay so he
would deny this yeah complementarity
perspective now you know in the end he
uh he
conceded but uh i love the story in the
book uh that you write you in the middle
of this
very serious i mean it's a popular
science book lenny's personality comes
across
but all of a sudden there's a story of
this medieval kingdom and the narrator i
listen to the audio version as well as
reading it he's got this
magical voice about these pollywogs
i i want to recommend it it's not just
for nerds like me it's it's for geeks
and dweebs everywhere
i'm getting a very technical question i
i know you're still in your pajamas
lenny
um what the very technical question you
might need your whiteboard for this one
what are your hobbies outside of physics
i don't have any anymore you know i
can't run anymore i can't do athletics
anymore
i'm too old for that i read a lot
i read and i read for fun what do you
read
whatever my wife tells me is good so
nonfiction fiction so you're not gonna
be reading losing the nobel prize
mostly mostly fiction mostly fiction
but i do intend i do intend the next
thing i will read
that my wife will have me read i i
a lot of my reading is to read to my
wife not because she can't read she can
read perfectly well but we do enjoy
reading together
uh right now we're reading a sort of
adventure book
called the eyes of venice by an italian
author whose name i can't remember uh
[Music]
it's quite good yeah but i suspect the
next thing we'll probably read when we
finish this thing
is barack barack obama's new book ah his
fourth memoir
i i hope to someday be worthy of writing
you know at least three memoirs but
i i don't think he writes well and yeah
well enough he writes well enough and
this is hard
he writes well enough that it's fun to
read out loud uh to each other
yeah i love the audiobook versions of
his books he's uh you know one
non-science guest that i'm uh
i'm trying to book on the into the
impossible show after you lenny
um so let's get back to some of the
stuff you brought up you are recognized
because wikipedia the repository of all
wisdom and knowledge of humanity
is says that you are one of the fathers
if not the father of string theory
of course we talked about the
inaccessibility or lack thereof
of testing the existence of a
singularity or maybe an
alternative to the big bang i want to
ask you on what grounds
should a theory be apprised uh your
friend uh murray gulm
gelman used to say you should have a
rubric a metric
that counts how many correct predictions
a theory makes and subtract the number
of incorrect predictions
and that should be on every theorist
forehead should be a mark of
of this this metric what what happens i
mean i'm not a pauperist i i don't i
don't believe in this demarcation that
oh
what's that a paparazzi that's right uh
so the paparazzi theorem just for those
that may not know is that only something
that can be falsified counts as true
science and i wonder
in my opinion that's always stemmed from
you know freud had penis envy you know
that some people had penis envy i think
that physicists have
mathematician envy because a
mathematician can prove what is not
provable or can
show via girdle what is are the limits
of a computational system or a
mathematical system
but in the lim in math in physics we
don't have such a thing so what should
we use and instead to gauge whether or
not i should send my
you know my son our daughter on an
adventure in string theory for example
yeah well okay so basically murray was
right
of course mario was right murray was
always right if you didn't believe him
just ask him
uh it's funny you say that because the
roger used to say um
it doesn't matter if you disagree or
agree with hawking you're on his side
because he would take
different the same side different sides
of the same position go on sorry okay
so mario's right you uh you know the
business is to make predictions
and uh and to test them out and see if
they work and if your theory
agrees with the uh predictions then it's
good if it doesn't that's bad
the problem is that it's in the nature
of the subject that the easy things get
done first
the things which take the shortest
amount of time to experimentally verify
other things which will be done first
that's almost a tautology that you do
the things first that you can do
things have gotten harder uh experiments
get harder
now to test to test uh physics
at the scale of 10 to the minus 17
centimeters
do i have that right 10 to the minus 15.
17 18 whatever it is a tev uh
it takes basically a scientific lifetime
to build a giant accelerator to build
the giant detectors and so forth
and that's just scratching the surface
the
things that we're interested in are far
more remote than that
so i think it's sort of unfair to use
the same criteria
that we would use in the old days where
uh faraday could test his
electromagnetic ideas
on his bench in his laboratory in uh
in 1850 or whenever it was you can't use
the same
uh for those kind of questions
however as far as string theory goes
remember string theory initially was a
theory of protons and neutrons and
mesons
there it has been tested and it's been
tested successfully
it's been tested successfully there are
no predictions of string theory
which didn't conform to what we know
about
hadrons and we know that they behave
like strings there is no doubt about
that at all
it's when it's translated into a theory
of gravity
and very very distant physics that there
are still some basic predictions
one of the basic predictions is the
existence of gravity
uh but
i would say that it's going to take a
time
it's going to take a lot of effort and
it is not something that's going to
happen overnight
and it's not so i don't know how long
it's going to take it may take 500 years
before we have experimental
direct proof my guess is long before
that we
will understand enough theory enough
theory to be quite convinced
that is a likely description of
elementary particles that it's a likely
description of cosmology
but the the the actual value of it at
the present time is different than that
the actual value of it is it's
the precise version of string theory is
highly consistent mathematical structure
that contains both gravitation and
quantum mechanics
and is in existence proof that quantum
mechanics and gravity
can fit together consistently
that they can and do fit together
consistently that's
not a small accomplishment right
um it absolutely is it's obviously
tremendous accomplishment and
it's so successful that so many people
have
um i don't want to say uh you know
attacked it but but
many people are now saying you know it's
been 40 50 years since an original idea
like string theory came out
a whole two or three generations of
theoretical physicists have
spent time on it there's no evidence for
supersymmetry as yet found at the lhc
um what do you do or what do you say
because i i never have seen you i've
seen you as the most
optimistic pessimist that i know i think
you are optimistic
uh in some ways but mostly you're a
realist and you're thinking um you know
you're advising
a young lenny uh and going going you
know back to graduate school
would it be in something like this or
would it be in technology what would you
advise somebody
uh before we turn to the question of the
necessity of theories of everything in
general what would you advise young
leonard as the tv show well first of all
i'm not in the business of
giving advice yes and when i i get at
least 25 emails a week or more
people asking me for advice how to
become a great physicist
or how to convince my parents i ought to
be a physicist or what
or what not and uh for the most part
i tend to try to answer some of them i'm
not all of them
uh i don't look i can't give you advice
i don't know what to tell you
um but if i you know what i would
well the advice i would have given
myself which would have been good advice
for me
is just follow your curiosity go
where your curiosity leads you pay no
attention to what
people are saying is or is not good
science
pay no attention to the poppers and the
uh and and whoever else i won't mention
names
who try to tell you what good science is
if you are curious
and you want to understand something
follow your nose and go
where your curiosity leads that's the
only thing i can say
i would say that to myself
and i think i would probably say it to
my students
and more than that i would i would think
that all of the very very good
theoretical physicists that i know
have done exactly that
and what do you make of this
proliferation of new theories of
everything that
attempt to maybe reconcile uh
different approaches to the issue of
unification of gravity
with the other three lower energetic
forces we have geometric unity
proposed by eric weinstein we have this
e8 monster group
uh exceptional group uh by garrett lisey
we have uh
we have stephen wolfram who's been on
the show as well uh discussing
his physics project why are there so
many theories of everything shouldn't
there be
only one
well i don't know it should only be one
i mean there is there was
some reality out there and there may be
many there may be more than one
uh description of it of course those
descriptions will have to be equivalent
but they may look different
um you know there are many versions of
classical mechanics
they are all consistent with each other
there's f equals m
a there's uh lagrangians and
hamiltonians and poisson brackets and
they're all
they all look different but they are all
equivalent
so that there should only be one and
and one may find or may find that these
different things that are being proposed
all do wind up being in some way
uh identical descriptions however the
particular ones that you've mentioned
either i don't know much about because i
haven't read about them
or i think they are probably silly
okay um right or both or both
now could it be that i'm wrong well of
course
yeah there's no limit to uh even great
minds even einstein was wrong reputedly
and i want to go there next
um so regardless of what you feel about
steven
uh steven uh about roger penrose's uh
conformal cyclic cosmology that violates
the second law of thermodynamics
he's written a book about that i have it
over here cycles of time
um in the end it seems destined that the
universe
in any case will be dying of of a
different type of entropic death the
heat then
um what will be left in in your mind
what is the most likely
end game for the universe just an
infinite tenuous void of black holes
uh forever emitting hawking radio what
do you see as the ultimate long game
and and please everybody out there keep
paying your taxes
because this is going long into the
future yeah
yes very long into the future um
the thing that i find most interesting
uh to say it's convincing i think i was
too strong
but the thing that i find most uh
interesting is this idea of
eternal inflation of andre linde
and other people who uh
their picture of what happens with the
universe is it does tend to recycle
itself
but not in the same way uh that uh not
in the deterministic
way that um roger imagines
but that fluctuations take place
fluctuations take place these
fluctuations
are one version of them are called
coleman de lucha instant ponds
which cause the universe to make
transitions to other
other types of environments
uh and this just goes on endlessly
forever and ever
and constantly renewing itself to some
extent
and potentially that might be right
but i think the real the
i i think i probably should just say i
don't know
i asked you before we began we began is
it okay
if you ask me a question and i say i
don't know
you said yes it's okay so
yes i i think i don't know i don't think
anybody knows
there are some things which are just
plain inconsistent with the laws of
physics
as we know it i think violating the
second law of thermodynamics is not a
good thing
but there are a lot of ideas out there
maybe
all of them violate the laws of physics
that would be a good thing
not because i think the laws of physics
are violated but as we discover that
they violate the laws of physics
well we can throw them away
yeah so that helps us winnow down the
field
yeah you talk a lot in the cosmic
landscape
about the multiverse as a as sort of a
a really a polemic all in a good way
argument against this anthropic or fine
tuning can you
explain why does that bother you because
i feel like in the anthropic principle
in some sense your colleague andre linde
who who i know
i i'm an advocate of the anthropocene no
i'm sorry
but but uh right so people like andre
linde will use that and say
uh he's been quoted as saying things
like why should there be
only one universe in other words that
it's almost more natural in his mind and
he says
almost that he has faith that there
should be other universes
um what what do you what do you mean
andre is an incredibly brilliant
physicist
he also has a bit of a spiritual side to
it it's not a religious it's not a
conventional religious side
but uh i don't know quite if the word
is spiritual or idealistic
and so forth my interest
in the anthropic idea in the multiverse
is much more hard-nosed than that
there are three things which uh
would push me in that direction let's
see if i can remember them
the first is that the universe is known
to be very very much
bigger than the part we can see that's
from the flatness of the uh
universe it's like uh it's like the
earth we know it's very very big because
it looks very flat
if we're standing in the middle of a
field some place and we look out all we
can see is a mile in every direction we
could say oh the earth may be no bigger
than a mile in every direction but no no
no that's not right it's so damn flat
that it must be much bigger than that
same with the universe
so we know it's enormously big we know
this fact about the cosmological
constant
it's absurdly small and it appears to be
very very fine-tuned
okay and we know that these eternal and
the the inflationary idea
works very well we know those those
three things
and they tend to lead the equations
themselves of trying to combine those
things together
oh we know something else we also know
that this is a string theory fact
the string theory facts are not as
reliable as other things why
because it may not be the right physics
right but
it seems to produce a vast vast number
of different solutions
of its own equations meaning a vast vast
number of different varieties of
possibilities
if you take all those things together
the fine-tuning of the cosmological
constant
the fact that inflation made the
universe enormously big
way way beyond what we can see and
uh and the large number of possibilities
inherent in string theory it's kind of
natural
to say maybe the universe is much bigger
and more diverse
than the region we can see it's natural
it fits with the equations
once we accept that that it's much much
bigger and more diverse
than we can see then it becomes natural
to say
well why is the universe like it is it's
like it is
because we live in the kind of region
that will support life
we don't ask that why don't we ask the
same question and get all exercised
about the anthropic principle when it
comes to living on the surface of the
earth
why do we live on the surface of the
earth is the earth is very fine-tuned it
happens to be very
in a very narrow range of temperatures
and environment why what's going on
there
why is it so fine-tuned well the stupid
answer is that if it weren't so
fine-tuned
we wouldn't be here to ask the question
so i find that
more or less convincing of a
convincingly
logical line of reasoning
the the people who dismiss it
tend to dismiss it on what i think of as
not scientific grounds
one of my friends will tell they'll tell
you that is a good friend
will tell you that's a bad idea because
it will encourage the young people not
to
ask for other solutions of the problem
now that's not a scientific answer
that's a cultural
sort of political answer um
and i don't know a good scientific
argument against
the multiverse anthropic idea i think
paul steinhardt would argue if he were
on the call that uh that you know it's
it's sort of the end of the scientific
method since i remember when we
participated i participated in the
bicep2 announcement see that's not a
scientific argument
that's a political and a cultural
argument it's the end of the
baloney who how do we know how science
is well let me give you an example lenny
so what happened was with bicep
we got uh we we made the announcement it
was there was a video at stanford with
andre and my friend charlene quo he's
your colleague there
and then there was a press conference at
harvard and then the same day
i had uh i had reports of people from
uh the discovery institute which is not
the discovery channel this is a
pro-religion mostly christian site
saying this proves god
exists because it's inexplicable
otherwise and then i had lawrence krauss
on the other hand saying also certain
nobel prizes await
because this removes the need for
supernatural shenanigans
so that you can have both sides and
furthermore
when we said uh when we made the
announcement it wasn't clear exactly
what the level of
tensors to scalar ratio was uh you know
there's always some uncertainty
but there was no single model that could
predict it and this brings me back to
the landscape that you've
really popularized and i think it's very
healthy to discuss these things
so one thing that's always confused me
if i change the
vacuum energy level the vacuum level in
our region of the universe by 0.1
electron volts
that doesn't change the law of universal
gravitation it doesn't change the speed
of light etc
why is it that in the landscape having
different vacuum expectation values
lead to different laws of physics not
just laws of constants as i understand
it did you hear me
yes oh something happened you froze for
a second oh sorry
so i'm asking you lenny why is it that
just the mere existence of the landscape
with 10 to the 500 different vacuum
states
why does that mean that we have
different laws of physics i could see
different constants but why would the
laws of physics depend on the veve
in a particular corner of the multiverse
okay that
that of course is an issue of what you
mean by the laws of physics
the laws of physics as we know them okay
what are the laws of uh physics on the
surface of the earth
one of the laws of physics is if you
drop something
from a height it will accelerate
uh what is it the sixth of the
acceleration
of the 9.8 meters per second yeah 9.8
meters per second
that's a constant of a that's a constant
of nature at least it's a constant of
nature on the surface of the earth
but it's also an environmentally
conditioned
it's true for the earth but it's not
true for other places
so i don't think people would say that
the laws of
physics are different on the earth
than they are on the moon because the
acceleration of gravity is different
but until we learn what those laws of
physics
are which are universal between the
earth
and the um and the moon
we have no choice but to say things are
different
and the constants of nature on the earth
are different than the constants of
nature
on the moon um it's more or less the
same thing
until we learn what those deeper and
overriding rules are that govern
everything
all we can say in this multiverse
picture
is that the constants of the constants
of nature
that we normally call the constants of
nature are different in this region from
that region
nobody wants the laws of physics
themselves if the full set of laws of
physics to depend on where you are
um and in fact i would say it
differently i would say
i think the vision is that it's not the
laws of physics that are different in
the different places
it's the solution to those laws of
physics not the equations themselves but
the solutions of those
equations the solutions might consist of
a collection of constants
or collection of numbers uh they could
be one thing could be another thing but
happen to be this particular thing in
our neighborhood
so if you mean by the laws of physics
the the deep
final laws of physics that we don't know
yet
i think everybody would like andre as
well as
everybody else who advocates this idea
is that those laws should be
one set of laws yeah i
i would uh think that would be most
elegant and parsimonious do you have a
few more minutes uh lenny for a few
final questions
yeah um so uh some questions from the
audience
uh that are wondering um
in the context of uh uh this is again
about
younger generations so um i wanna say oh
somebody's asking about the
fascination with life outside of the
earth why
why is it that we spend billions of
dollars to look for signatures of
water on mars or whatever what do you
think about the human
curiosity or what have you um uh impels
us to spend so much more on that than
say on fundamental particle physics
oh well is it obvious i mean
particles are very remote things
they're too tiny to see too tiny to
touch
um it uh just uh
am i more accurate a good question am i
more curious
about particles well joe after all very
boring
the particles don't have very much
associated with them they have a
a mass and a spin that's about it
they're very very in a charge and a
charge
yeah they have a few parameters and
commodities can't talk to them you can't
uh
am i more curious about them than i are
about whether there is life in the
universe
i would say it's a different kind of
curiosity
one i as a physicist am very interested
in
fundamental particles because i think
they may lead
to something deeper than themselves they
may lead to an understanding which is
much deeper
than themselves uh but it's very hard to
get at
but i as just a as a human being as an
ordinary human being
i'm terribly curious about whether there
are whether there's life out there
whether i could communicate with it and
so forth
so i find it very easy to understand why
people
as a whole would be more interested in
life out there
than they would be in these exceedingly
dull objects
which are truly stupid they have no
consciousness that the bit though
they're only interesting in so far as
they could
ultimately lead to something much deeper
than themselves
uh someone's asking me your opinions
about the simulation hypothesis and
again it's okay if you don't know
or want to comment on it yeah i don't
know
um the simulation hypothesis means what
do we live in a computer
yeah that you're basically assuming
you're being simulated i'm being
simulated because ai is going to
increase so rapidly
income and according to nick bolstrom
and others that
the overwhelming likelihood of life is
that it's all artificial as max tegmark
wrote about in life 3.0 okay i don't
know what it means to say
we certainly live in a world where there
are laws of physics which
predict the which predict how systems
have evolved
they have laws the world has laws those
laws could be thought of as a computer
program
if you like uh or is analogous to a uh
to a computer program computer program
that tells you what happens next a
quantum computer that tells you
if the state of the universe as the
state of the computer as such and such
in the next instance it will be such and
such well we do seem to live in a world
with laws
the laws could be thought of as
algorithms for updating what happens
next
i think the real question is not whether
we live in such a world
where there's an algorithmic sense of
what happens next but whether it was put
there whether it was put in place
with a purpose is there an intelligence
is there a computer programmer an
intelligence who created it for a
purpose that i haven't got the vagus
idea
was was the world created by an agency
an intelligence or something
that was trying to do a computation
i personally think not but uh
but uh it seems to me could be could be
one of my uh subscribers is asking a
question i don't fully understand
patrick is asking
about the holodeck or holographic i
think he means the holographic
universe principle was that startling uh
to discover or come upon or invent
first of all do you believe that physics
theoretical physics is invented or
discovered just
yes one word answer you don't have to go
into a deep
discourse well i think it's i i think
it's a combination of both um that's
exactly what jim simon says both yeah
it's a combination of
the ways of the ways of describing and
thinking about
an objective fact might might be
somewhat
variable from civilization to
civilization they may all be equivalent
and there may be some inventiveness in
describing a way of thinking about
things
the way mathematics is described that
the equal sign
for example is two horizontal dashes one
over the other
that's an invention in fact even the
whole idea of
an equal sign on the left and a right
is an invention on the other hand it's
describing something which we think is
more
objective than just the the
pretty pictures that we use to describe
it so i think the same is true of
physics
ways of describing things are human
inventions
the things that they're describing
hopefully are not
so maybe he means that uh you know the
holographic universe is connected to
this yeah
so um uh right so coming to the end here
just a few more final questions
from the audience and then i have a
couple of questions i ask all my
all my uh guests and if you'll if you'll
indulge me and
have some forbearance i will ask you
them as well uh
so what about consciousness i had noam
chomsky on the podcast recently
and i came away as i have for my
discussions with him and sir roger
basically feeling they don't really know
what consciousness is and
uh they're all kind of speculating this
thomas nagel uh essay
you know and the hard problem it's
really hard
harder than than maybe string theory to
verify or move past what are your
thoughts on consciousness if any
and i realize you're still in your
pajamas so you may not be fully
conscious
right look um
people like myself tend to make
tremendous fools of themselves
when they start to talk about things
that they know nothing about
thinking that their great expertise at
something else
qualifies them uh
okay that being said that being said now
speculate away use your
subject matter expertise yeah okay
um of course i don't know
i don't know how consciousness works i
don't know what it is it seems to be a
thing i feel conscious
uh and so i think it's a thing but my
guess is
this is just a guess my guess is the way
the route to
understanding it probably lies in
computer science
in building machines which get to be
more and more conscious like
and eventually understanding what makes
one machine behave conscious like
in the other machine not behave
conscious like of course we could do
that with a human brain
you know but we're not going to go into
the human brain dissect it
and pull apart its neurons and so forth
we can't do that
um i i guess i also think that
consciousness is something that we
probably can't
just the practicalities of it we
probably can't engineer
engineering something means
building an algorithm uh intentionally
to do that my guess would be it's so
complex and so difficult that the only
thing you can do is
evolve it evolve it the way nature did
but evolve it in a computer
big enough computers complex enough
computers computers which interact with
each other
maybe eventually we will begin to
understand
through computer science through ai
through and its connection with
neuroscience and its connection with
neuroscience
perhaps we will begin to see patterns
emerge
in what kind of things exhibit
consciousness
that i would think is the hope for uh
eventually understanding it now that
i've made a grain fool of myself let's
uh we'll move on they actually none
other than galileo
galilei uh speculated on the nature of
thoughts
and uh noam chomsky calls it the galileo
problem
uh speaking of galileo he is visiting
right now
here in la jolla yeah here he is
uh i think we need a a finger puppet of
you and here's one of carl sagan
uh we'll get one of you and then we can
really stick it to you um
lenny i want to ask you what heroes
would you most like to meet from that
are no longer with us
uh who would you like to have uh have a
physics conference with as i said in the
very beginning one of the most touching
endearing parts of black hole war
is that it made me nostalgic for the
times i could get together with my
colleagues
and that my young students are missing
out on the congeniality
of in-person gatherings if you could
have an in-person gathering
who would you invite uh of a great
physics from the great physicist of your
okay so let me ask who would i like to
have coffee with
yes okay yeah there are two particular
figures
many many but uh but there are two
particular figures that have always
intrigued me a great deal
one of them is the ancient greek
aristarchus
yes aristarchus was way he's not this
famous as aristotle
but he was far more of a greater
scientist he was the greatest scientist
of the ancient world by far
he was the one who first figured out and
for good reasons
that the heliocentric theory um
copernicus recognized that and quotes
him
but he figured out so many brilliant
things that
sort of was semi-lost to history because
his writings disappeared
i would love to talk to aristarchus and
see what he thinks
about how things evolved after him okay
he might have been a very boring man who
knows
but there is one person that has always
not just fascinated me but i sort of
feel close to
in some and that's michael faraday
michael faraday was of course he he had
this
pictorial way of thinking
that i find very close to my own way of
thinking closing your eyes and
visualizing he visualized the lines of
flux
magnetic fields electric fields but he
also had
something that i admire tremendously an
ability to explain
and a desire to explain to the general
public
what science was about i don't know if
you've ever read his christmas lectures
yes christmas his christmas lectures to
to the working man basically
on how electricity and things work a
marvelous
marvelous expository um and he knew very
little formal math right
yes he knew very little formal math but
he had this
immense ability to visualize how nature
worked
and uh so michael faraday was somebody
who has been
a hero for me
and maybe that is lenny a segway that
will get
some resolution to your um uh this
this pleasure or propensity not to give
advice
maybe the advice is to follow these
people or at least learn about them
i feel like if i met a painter i would
say uh you want to be a painter okay
paint monet paint every piece that monet
and picasa ever painted and you'll be
pretty good and that's what you do
in the theoretical minimum which is a
wonderful segue thanks thinking
i'm hurting myself on the by patting
myself on the back the theoretical
minimum i'm recommending that to a very
brilliant he's actually the son
of eric weinstein i'll get into that
some other time but he's a brilliant 15
year old kid and
my course of education for him and
tutoring him somewhat
is that i want him to go through the
theoretical minimum
and go through those books i think he'll
come out with this wonderful
exposure to the foundations and it's not
pure mathematical there's mathematics
but there's also your
love of teaching comes through and i'm
going to put links to all your great
lectures online i want to finish if
you'll indulge me with a little more
forbearance lenny three more questions
and then i'll let you go back to bed um
i'm not going back to that
so kamron vaffa is coming on the show
next week as i said
and uh i'll uh i don't know did you fix
any of his uh faucets or toilets uh back
no
no no comrade is much younger than me
he's a little older than me
yeah he has this wonderful book called
puzzles to unlock the universe
and in it he talks about his favorite
puzzles and and one of them being
the um the icing model he basically goes
through what is the icing model and
why it's so interesting and it brings up
spontaneous symmetry breaking
i wonder what do you have a favorite
puzzle do you have a way of thinking
about
um you know things that is purely for
maybe
amusement but like solving a puzzle once
you solve it you want to go back and do
it again
you know i can't the answer must be yes
but i
but they've caught me unaware so go on
to the next one because i can't think of
a quick answer to that
okay yeah um i think michaelson the
great michelson said
something like uh all experimentalists
are puzzle solvers because they're just
like little kids they want to go back
and
redo the puzzle and and i always point
out that physicists are a lot like kids
because
they love solving puzzles they're very
curious they don't play well with others
they fight they're jealous
they they have all these petty emotions
it's interesting as
as a young person i loved solving
puzzles you know
i loved solving you know
semi-mathematical
logical puzzles and things like that as
i got
older i sort of lost interest in it
and i think that's because everything i
did was puzzle solving
and uh and yeah that's the same reason i
don't read much science fiction because
yeah even though i'm at the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination i am
uh
duty bound to do it okay final three
questions i ask all my guests
uh on the into the impossible podcast um
so there's a concept of what's called an
ethical will
and actually alfred nobel uh it's
actually a jewish concept you know that
from your decades of torah study as
a young man right so it's called the
zava ah
and uh it comes from genesis so we won't
get into the to the theology of it all
but uh but
but the point is that people leave
ethical wills actually barack obama has
an ethical will you can find it online
and it's what you'd want to give away to
to the future to your in posterity not
material will so alfred nobel
all wanted to recognize great inventions
and discoveries but he also
did so wanted to do so for the benefit
of all mankind
is there anything that you would want to
leave as as an ethical
uh will to your not only to your
biological children grandchildren great
grandchildren but to your uh
to your ideological children of which i
count myself as a member
well that's that's that's a hard
question um
you know we're in a situat we're in a
situation right now
which is so fraught with
lack of ethical standards and i not
among everybody of course
but among some people um
i uh oh boy
i i don't have a i don't have an answer
to that
the only thing i can say is um if you
are
if you care at all about the world
you've got to speak out
that's phenomenal you've got you've got
to speak out and you've got
to say clearly what you stand for
and what you believe in and i know i'm
talking about political things
and uh you know as well as i do how
fraught things are
and how dangerous the world is how
and i would want my
descendants both intellectual and
biological
to know that i did speak out and that i
did
oppose what i consider
evil tendencies in our society i think
you know what i'm talking about i don't
have to spell it out
yeah and um
fair enough but you know i don't think i
hate to break it to you but you have
many
many biblical notions because that's the
actual quote is said exotic to your
dough you shall pursue justice
justice with all your might yes that's
really what you're saying and
you've spoken about that on many
occasions and i
you know i think one of the uh great
traits that you exhibit we'll get to in
the question after this one and that's
your courage but before we get there
you've seen the movie 2001 a space
odyssey i hope i did
i couldn't figure it out but i enjoyed
it so there's a lot of mysterious
baffling things in that movie including
these weird
ominous monoliths these black objects
placed on the savannah of africa
later on the surface of the moon and um
i think of them as time capsules meant
to be found when humanity
is mature enough to appreciate the
lessons encapsulated within this
billion-year-old time capsule what would
leonard suskin
put on a time capsule guaranteed to last
for a billion years
well it asked me something easier
what it's the last two questions you
can't you can't say i don't know until
the final three questions it's my only
rule
well the answer is i haven't thought of
it and that's a big big question it's a
big big question
and uh requires thought and i haven't
thought about it that's what i would
answer
you don't have a favorite equation or
discovery of yours that you string
theory the foundational equations of
string theory
well foundational equations of string
theory won't mean anything to a
civilization which has lost
its knowledge of newton's equations
uh so okay
so there'll be no point in that if a
thousand years or 10 000 or 20 000 years
civilization goes through some upheavals
and manages to lose a large amount of
the knowledge that it now has
what would i want it to remember so they
could get started again
not necessarily as feynman said you know
he he was asked a similar question
he said that the world is made of atoms
which are an indivisible you know what
what fact of of physics have you do you
find most kind of worthy of preservation
not not to reboot society 2.0 but
but more most remarkable discovery that
the human mind has
come up with or discovered
i am very partial to the second law of
thermodynamics
very partial to it uh
and uh beyond that
quantum entanglement how about that
quantum entanglement fair enough and
actually that dovetails nicely to your
uh to your fascination with with uh
entropy and the marriage of the two of
them surprisingly
fascinatingly at the surface of a black
hole the stretch to rise
exactly last question lenny before i uh
let you
go out for your cup of coffee with your
wife um
so we've gone into the future both in
what you'd leave for
humanity kind of as an ethical will and
even discussed what would happen on a
time capsule or what you'd put on a time
capsule
but i want to ask you now going
backwards in time so sir arthur c
clarke had all these famous laws the
first one is any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic his second law states that for
every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert
and his third law is the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible and that's how i got
the name for this podcast it's called
into the impossible for that very reason
what thing about your life mystified you
or did you think was impossible
and then thanks to your courage was
eminently doable
because you had the you had the vision
and the intensity to go into the
impossible
yeah well i'm not sure it quite answers
the question but there's a there's a
quotation that i've always liked and
admired because i think it really does
reflect
things about the way i think and it's a
quotation
of the famous detective you know which
detective
sherlock mr holmes i presume right now
how the hell did it go
when you have eliminated all
that is impossible
whatever remains must be the truth i do
do you know the percentage yes once you
have once you eliminate the impossible
whatever remains no matter how
improbable must be
the truth so arthur conan doyle right
no that was sherlock holmes yes
no no you can't give that to arthur
conan doyle it's it's sherlock holmes
i'll cite that his his h index is too
low
right um i always felt a lot of my life
went that way
that i in my life i mean my scientific
life
that i've tried i
was up against puzzles which i didn't
understand
and i kept looking for solutions looking
for solutions looking for solutions
always in the back of my mind was that
was that one
crazy solution that
i was afraid of because it was just too
unlikely but eventually
everything else failed and you realized
it was all that was left
the holographic principle is a
particular example of that now of course
that was
not only me that was also harada tuft
but that i had sensed that
long before but just kept thinking
that's too crazy that the world
is uh as a kind of hologram
and just pushing against the problem in
particular the problem that stephen
hawking had raised
and looking for this solution that
solution and eventually i realized
that's that's got to be it there's
nothing else left
and so i always admired sherlock's
uh
quote did that answer the question
probably
nothing to do with the question but it
did it did it in fact it did me better
because now i've got another question to
ask my future guest
i'm going to ask shelly that tomorrow
i'm going to say uh
none other than sir leonard suskin so i
want to remind folks
that tomorrow i'll have on shelly
glashow please send me questions
uh for him i've already gotten one from
our esteemed guest uh professor
leonard suskin and in your honor leonard
tomorrow is the leonid meteor shower
so we've arranged for that so when you
look up from northern california
know that i'm thinking about you and i
will send you some meteorites someday
as i do to my some of my subscribers to
my newsletter these are actual
meteorites space dust from 4.2 billion
years old
some collected from the leonid meteor
shower in honor of leonard suskin
i want to thank you leonard uh thank you
so much you've been
a wonderful guest and you've been an
inspiration and even though
you can't remember meeting me we did
meet and i can now say i met a living
lenny legend and i want to thank you so
much for going into the impossible and
wish you all the best and i hope we'll
stay in touch
thank you thank you